when i i first hosted my uh i hosted my
first event
in june and the event happened or i
decided to do it around june 1st
and the event went place seven weeks
later in august
and when i started i had close to
nothing i had
a 200 person email list so there wasn't
like this oh it's easy for you you had
the hustle no no it didn't exist
uh there was no website there was just a
domain name called hustle cut
um and i hosted this event in the first
six weeks it made about sixty thousand
dollars
in revenue and fifty ish
thousand dollars in profit and a lot of
people were surprised by that it was but
it wasn't that hard the second event
you can see here explain so how did you
sell the sixty thousand dollars of
tickets during that process
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back today sean
let's actually jump right you i think
want to do this billy of the week right
away
and then i have a thing on events do you
want to do events or you want to save
that what do you want to do
i want to do that so i want to do this
billy of the week i want to hear your
stuff on paid events
and then i have two ideas one is a cool
idea i've seen and then the other is a
brainstorm of a potential idea
so i want to do all those things so
let's start with let's start with the
billy of the week
um this one is very interesting have you
ever heard of this guy before don't
don't google it i want to tell you the
story so don't don't google this guy
all right let me tell you a picture i'm
just i i google them i'm just thinking
oh wow
okay yeah uh young guy young guy 29
years old i don't know who he is
his name is wow sam bankman freed i
think it's the way you say his name
and uh when you if you heard him talk
like i actually want you to
listen to a youtube video for a second
because he sounds like you know
an absolute dweeb and i loved it i was
like oh this guy
sounds like he would be a self-made
billionaire by the age of 29 because he
sounds like a genius he sounds like a
tech genius have you
brought this person up to me before no i
just discovered him like two days ago
okay so what's this guy's story
so this guy you know i'll just come sam
for short but
uh so this guy sam he's a he
he's a young guy he's very smart um he
takes a job as kind of like a hedge fund
trader or something like that with a
group called jane street i guess
and uh i don't know i forget these
details they don't really matter guys
got a job in finance
and he leaves and he starts something
called
alameda research and it's called alameda
research
because he needed it to sound as legit
as possible and not
like what it actually was so what was it
so what this guy did was
he was into crypto and there was this
known thing in crypto where
as crypto was getting popular this is
around 2017 when the first big
run-up happened and bitcoin went you
know from three thousand dollars to
twenty thousand dollars and it crashed
later but
during that time 2016 2017 2018 bitcoin
was
emerging and there was this as any new
thing there's these like kind of
uh it's like the wild wild west a little
bit and so there was this thing where
in the u.s the price of bitcoin was
let's say 10
000 of bitcoin and in other countries
where
um the exchanges weren't built or the
com the country had some regulations or
whatever
there was like a premium for bitcoin
there was more demand than there was
bitcoin available to buy
in those countries uh because you need
like let's say
like in korea there was a famous uh
thing called the kimchi
the kimchi premium and the kimchi
premium was that in korea
there wasn't kimchi like the uh
like the the food so this was known as
the kimchi premium and basically it was
like
uh whatever bitcoin was selling for here
let's say it was ten thousand dollars in
korea it was trading for fifteen
thousand dollars because it was that
bigger
fifty percent premium and it fluctuated
obviously and i think 30
was kind of like the average of the
kimchi premium over time so everybody
wanted this
so everybody you know any smart person
saw oh wow there's an arbitrage what if
i could just buy it in the u.s for 10
grand
and immediately sell it in korea for 15
grand or for 30 you know 13 grand
and so you had this like ability to flip
it and so a whole bunch of people
were trying to do this but there was all
these problems right like well
the reason you know the reason wasn't
easy the reason there was this premium
is because it was hard
to buy bitcoin in korea so one idea was
you buy it in the u.s off a u.s exchange
you go to korea and you sell it but
you're gonna sell it for in the korean
you know
wan which is like the local currency but
now you need to like
for the for the arbitrage to continue
you have to convert the korean wand back
to dollars
to go buy more go buy more bitcoin in
the us
the problem was you can't convert the
korean wand back to dollars easily
because the government was very like
tight fisted regulations
you couldn't funnel large amounts of
money from the korean wand back to
dollars very very easily
so a whole bunch of people were trying
to get this like pinata of money
and they couldn't crack it and what this
guy did was he was like okay [__] the
kimchi premium he went for the japan
premium which was far less appealing it
was only 10
but he's like still if i can if i could
trade a u.s bitcoin for 10
more in japan every day i'm making 10
compounding daily and so he went through
this like odyssey where for like a year
all he's doing is setting up this trade
so he like
for actually by the way first when he
was trying to figure out could i capture
the kimchi premium
he was like doing calculations like if i
filled up if i chartered a private plane
and i filled it up with a hundred people
and i flew you know they buy bitcoin in
the us and i flew them all to korea
and then they they you know sell it
there and then i could each one of them
could convert some amount of that money
and i could fly them back and every day
i could fly this plane back and forth
between us and korea like could i make
it work
and he was like i don't think it works
so wait so you had to be there
physically it's not that you had to be
there physically you have to do all like
all
legs of the transaction so you have to
be able to buy in korea or like
sell your bitcoin in korea at the
premium but now you have korean wan now
you need to convert that to dollars
and so how do you do that you need to
convert it there but there's caps they
won't let you convert it because
the way he described it is like look
he's like what i wanted to do
essentially was to be you know selling
five million dollars of bitcoin for the
local currency and converting five
million of local currency back to us
dollars
every day it's like if you if you just
go to like go to korea go to japan go to
wherever and you say hey i'd like to
it's like a one-way flow of money i have
five million dollars of your local
currency i'd like to convert it to
dollars and exit the country
um and they're like okay but where are
you getting all this money and why are
you doing such a large amount
like what is this yeah he's like you
know if you if you go to bank school 101
that's like money laundering that's what
money laundering looks like that
that is what money laundering that is
exactly what money laundering looks like
so he's like even though i'm not money
laundering
i'm buying and selling a good that's
differently priced in different regions
to them on the ground to the bank on the
ground where i need to do these
conversions
it's shady it's too shady they won't let
me do it so he spends like
a year of his life where he's like goes
to japan
now he's got to find uh he's got to do
each
each one of these was hard so anyways
the net end of this story is this guy's
arbitraging 25 million dollars a day of
of this currency he's making a 10
compounding uh you know margin
every single day and this guy you know
in the three years basically he's become
a self-made billionaire he's worth 10
billion dollars now which is a
combination of
the money he made from the arbitrage
trade as well as
he then created his own exchange um
and like you know so he has a trading
company that's you know has made
hundreds of millions of dollars on this
arbitrage
and then he built he used that to create
an exchange which is worth billions of
dollars on paper
so anyways this guy's worth 10 billion
dollars he
and his because uh the currency is
called ftx right right that's his
exchange
his exchange called fps oh sorry sorry
exchange and
uh that is is that basically an
alternative to
basically a more higher end it's a more
sophisticated coinbase where you can do
like derivatives trades option trades on
all different types of credits
internationally and that's like and
that's like a proper company it's a
proper company with like so
many research made hundreds of millions
of dollars in the span of a few months
just doing this one trade over and over
again every day so i'm going to describe
a couple things but
he got on people's radar because he was
the biggest donor to joe biden this year
in the campaign he wrote a he wrote like
a five million dollar check at the last
hour like at the 11th hour
that let joe do like you know as part of
this like you know last minute blitz
they did on tv ads
in all the swing states uh because this
this kind of interesting this guy's like
very
uh his whole business philosophy is this
thing called effective altruism
which is basically like go be a greedy
capitalist go try to make as much money
as you can
and your goal is to give at least half
of it away while you're doing it
so he's got like it's not like a
philanthropist giving away one percent
of his money or 10 of his money as a tie
his goal is giving away like 50 of his
liquid liquid
like net worth you know like that he
makes every year that's his like kind of
like his mindset
where did he get the money to start this
so he started it with a very small
amount of money and it just compounded
very quickly
because he's basically getting 10 extra
every day so i
i don't know exactly where he got the
initial seed capital or how big it was
he hasn't
specified that but he did say at the max
they were doing 25 million a day
on the trade which is basically like a
2.5 million
like you know like profit per day uh
that they were making on the trade and
so
he describes that okay so
he's like basically if you want to do
this you have to like break it down into
small chunks
he's like okay so i need on one side i
need to be able to go buy a [__] ton of
bitcoin in the u.s
so how do i get exchange in the u.s
that's going to give me really high
limits even though i'm this dorky kid
who's got no track record and i have no
like
collateral or brand name and so he's
like finds a way to solve that problem
of like being able to buy
25 million dollars of bitcoin in the u.s
then he had to like
go to japan and he had to be able to
sell a huge amount of bitcoin there
then he had to be able to convert it
from the japanese yen or whatever
to us dollars and he had to do that all
in the same day and wire transfer it all
back to the us to buy it again the next
day to buy the full max amount to get
the next time
every day and so he described like they
would just the way that the timing
worked
it was always in the last hour of the
banking day that he would be trying to
get all the wire transfers done
to get the money back to the us so that
they can execute tomorrow's trade and
any day that they couldn't what does he
sound like
you said he sounds crazy like i'm
looking at pictures oh my god he sounds
extremely genuine
humble high-pitched voice kind of like
just a nerdy guy
um who was like he accounted for about
ten percent of all the bitcoin trading
himself his alameda research during that
time period
i believe which is just like insane
because he was moving so much money dude
i love
these people i love i love freaks this
guy is a freak
this is his setup you know his desk is
him with six monitors hanging above his
head
his neck is like cramped because he just
needs to constantly monitor the spot
price in the u.s what's the price in
japan
what's the conversion of yen to dollars
what's the conversion of dollars here
it is it's just constantly and any time
anything broke
it was just costing them tons of money
and he had always had to make sure
nobody's gonna like stop his trade to
stop the bottleneck and then he's stuck
with all this like japanese yen and
can't move it
or it gets seized by the government and
so he was like the main banks wouldn't
work with him
so that's why he picked alameda research
as a name to like be more legit
he hired like this like kind of like
sophisticated guy like who spoke the
local language to be able to go talk to
the bankers and be like hey here's what
we're doing
he also like went to like these rural
banks in japan not the main ones in the
city
he's like okay these rural banks will
take my business because they're like
more open to what i'm doing than like
the citibanks that are like you know
have a tighter filter on what i'm doing
so anyways i just thought it was super
interesting to like
he identified one arbitrage like
moneyball style
and then dedicated like a year or 18
months of his life to just hammering
this one arbitrage and ended up making
hundreds of millions of dollars and
uh parlayed that into becoming you know
his paper net worth is 10 billion
dollars
and he did that i think four years total
of how he built
10 billion because the because the
exchange
the combination of the research the the
trading company plus the exchange
um 10 billion is what he what he
estimates is his net worth to be
god i love people like this i um i mean
that's astounding there's very he's
that's one of a kind
but i love people and i try to do this
with the hustle with email addresses
uh with an email list but that's peanuts
compared to this and what some other
people do but basically who take
a small tiny kind of like silly thing
and just amp it up on steroids so i
love that i think that is the coolest
thing i love people who think like that
i think it's so fascinating um i'd have
to think of some more examples of that
but you totally know what i mean right
yeah
absolutely i've met this before with
like people who make a poker bot
it's like what are you doing it's like
every day there's tweaking this little
bot that's running 24 7 at the
at the one and two cent tables of full
tilt poker
and they have this like small edge like
this like 15 percent edge
and then they're just like tweaking the
system and and what it reminds me of is
what happens a lot of times is people
will go buy information they'll go say
oh i pay i pay
like my uncle does this he was paying 19
a month for like this guy's like
stock tips i had to like sit my uncle
down and be like
look like if these are amazing stock
tips do you really think this guy's
going to give it to you for 19
like no like you know if this guy really
had an edge in the market
he would not need to make money
educating you he would be
pounding his advantage right and trying
to make as much money as he can as long
as that window exists
and so like oh i have another example
this this guy on twitter called
haralabob do you follow him
no pretty fascinating guy to follow so
this guy is a high stakes gambler
he's a professional gambler which
usually is an oxymoron
uh like there's no such thing as a
professional gambler but he he was a
professional sports bettor and what he
realized was back in
i think 26 i forgot it was 2013 20 2012
i don't remember when it was like
maybe it was even longer than that i
think it might have been like 15 years
ago now
he realized that in vegas the books were
like
they were so sports books it's kind of
like hard to beat the house the bookies
are always like spot on
and there's one type of bet called the
you know over under
it's basically like in basketball it's
like what's the total score going to be
is it going to be
if you add up the total of both teams is
it 200 more and you bet if it's gonna be
over or under that
and the over under is really really
accurate but what he noticed was that
um he noticed two things one was the
bookies did not take into account that
actually in the first half
like in the basketball game the second
half the score is usually higher than
the first half
because at the end of the game the team
that's losing will start fouling
uh because they're like look we have to
try to get back in this game so i'll
follow you
to save the clock stops you get two free
throws and then i'll come back try to
hit a three
and so that's usually the end game for
most most teams like if you're down you
foul the other team
clock stops uh they score while the
clock is stopped
and then i try to shoot threes to get
back in the game and i'm pretty
desperate
so what he noticed was that the total
over under if you just divided it by
half that's what they would
just 50 that's what they were making as
the first half over under
and very few people bet the first half
over under because it's not that fun of
a bet it's like
who cares what the halftime score is
gonna be if you're gonna bet the score
you just bet the end of the game score
um so he realized it was a small edge
where
they thought they were taking the full
score and dividing by half and making
that the line
he's like oh my god this is almost
always going to be under and he
specifically noticed that these three
teams
their coaches would like do that foul
strategy way more in the second half
so he's like okay there's these teams
that these coaches do this strategy more
and the first half is like my arbitrage
and he doesn't say [__] to anybody
he just starts hiring people to go to
the books all the different what's this
person's
name this guy harala bob and i'm kind of
like
i'm kind of paraphrasing about that it's
h-a-r-a-l-a-b-o-b
harala bob and so um and now he works
for mark q he works for the dallas
mavericks i think he works for mark
cuban
because he like wow got a big
personality on twitter because he was
the sports bettor and like the way he
made all of his money was like
he had identified over these like 10
years of being a sports bettor he found
like three different
edges one was he just like went super
hard on the shaq and kobe lakers
the second was this first half like uh
first half over under bet that was just
mispriced and he just took that missed
pricing and he just went all in on this
miss pricing
wow this guy was crazy anytime a sports
book would limit him he would then like
pay a guy
like hey go walk up and bet 25 000 of
this game please and then
he was like do that he had like people
betting at all the sports books in all
the different casinos at the same time
so that he could be betting the type of
money he wanted to bet
to maximize his advantage while this
arbitrage existed
and so uh anyways i love people who find
these arbitrages and then like
the lengths that they have to go through
to maximize it it's like the movie
21 where they're counting cards in vegas
and they're like strapping cash to their
body
walking through this airport because
they like need to go
like palpable you used to have this guy
who worked for you named steve
or stephen i think yeah um he and then
he so basically
if i remember correctly what he did was
he would create these
i don't know if he created like so he
would buy
a really small twitter handle that was
called like
today in history and it would just tweet
like a picture of
what happened 50 years ago you know uh
jfk was shot
uh then he would buy like a cool car
twitter one where it was like uh here's
all interesting cars and then like i
can't believe it it could fly which is
like weird flying devices that
when you look at them they look silly
and he eventually bought i believe
hundreds of them to the point of where
he built a business so he did one of he
did two things that were interesting the
story you said was
he goes basically i control the internet
let me show you how by the end of the
talk i'm going to
have x trend right like i'm going to
have this
thing from the audience he'd be like say
a word and people like gobbly [__] he
said all right cool
while we're talking um in 30 minutes
we'll just set a clock here we're going
to check twitter in 30 minutes
and then sure enough gobbledygook would
be trending on twitter the number one
trend in all of europe
because his would all start talking
about gobbledygook in meme format
and it would just like start to go viral
basically and nobody even knew it so
what he
and he he parlayed this into getting
sponsorships
and now i don't know if you know him
anymore i don't know him at all yeah but
i
i read about him and i and this company
went public
it went public in a really shady way so
i don't know if i believe everything
there's
something about it i don't have too much
evidence it's just a roll-up of a bunch
of
bunch of media companies something was
weird about it but basically
i think it went public in england for
like two or three hundred million
dollars market cap and so it turned him
into quite wealthy
uh quite wealthy by the way he
personally i think he just released a
book called
uh what is it happy sexy millionaire
sexy millionaire yeah so
go buy steve's book um yeah so anyway
he found miss price assets so i remember
the first one that he
uh discovered was one that was like [__]
freshmen say or is like fr
like but you know whatever the the the
uk slang for that is
it's basically like a me a parody
account that tweeted out funny things
that freshmen say on a college campus
and what he found the reason it was
mispriced was most of these accounts
were made
by accident by somebody who was 18 years
old and 16 years old and they were bored
at home and they just made a
you know like harry potter you know
harry potter jokes
twitter account and it gets to a million
followers and they don't know what to do
with it and then they kind of like
they get paid like 75 bucks on venmo to
like shout out some app
or like they get paid like 200 to like
say a protein powder or
like or they would make a blog selling
you know like protein powder and they
would just
like try to funnel some traffic to that
but it didn't like make sense it wasn't
very sophisticated
he needed he needed promotion for his
business so he was working with these
guys then he realized
screw my business this is just a really
powerful promotional engine
we used him uh early on when he was you
know we brought him on
he was part of my team we used him and
we became the number one app in the uk
number one app in europe because we used
his like network to like
talk about our app and what he had the
insight was was that you don't say
like our app was bebo at the time so it
wasn't go download bebo it's a great app
no he's like that [__] doesn't work i
was like well we need that and we need
the link in there so we can track how
many clicks he gets he's like
no that's not how people talk on the
internet i was like okay so tell me what
do you mean
he's like you got to think like what you
want to do is we have so many accounts
that we want somebody when they scroll
on twitter they see
bebo mentioned like seven times and that
they don't even nobody's explaining it
nobody's selling it to them
they just realized why is everyone
saying this thing biba what is that and
then they go google it or they go search
for it
and then they actually download the app
because they think this is what's hot
this is what people are talking about
he's like so
what we'll do is we'll make content
that's like
um you know my mom when she sees me
check bibo for the 50th time today and
it's a meme of the mom throwing your
phone out the window
and it's like so the the implied
meaning is that bibo is this addictive
app that you keep checking that your
parents hate that you keep checking
well what is that app why would why
would this person check that out 50
times i don't even have that app never
heard of it
right and so that was the genius of his
marketing like tactics at that time
um and then he had the audience to back
it up so they got spotify and microsoft
and all these companies to pay them
tons of money because anytime they
needed to spread the word about a new
thing that they were doing
this was the most effective way to reach
a bunch of people a bunch of young
people and so then he parlayed that he
started right launching his own consumer
brand so if they have a bunch of food
accounts
they would launch like a food
subscription product or they had a bunch
of fitness accounts
they would launch like a women's
athletic wear you know like company
it didn't all work but man like crazy
ass like business that came
you know if you if you want to go
research it it's called
social starts right social chain social
chain uh steve
what's his embarrassment yeah you should
follow him on twitter he's a great
follow
uh now he tweets out just like i don't
know inspirational [__] all the time
like motivational stuff yeah he's like a
mini gary vee
although he's like a better garyvee to
be honest with you probably a ghetto
yeah
he's probably gonna give him like five
years and he's gonna be much bigger than
what gary v is today i think
um if he sticks with it but uh yeah and
there's some articles that are cool if
you go search like the 21 year olds that
control the internet i think there's
like a vice article like 22 year olds
control
buzzfeed buzzfeed yeah so buzzfeed
advice did like crazy articles about
them
i mean at one point they had 25
employees that were all under the age of
22 years old
and they were all just managing these
media accounts and they were just making
tons of money and they like
yeah it was insane they built like an
office with like a playpen inside and
you know like no it's a good article is
it so do you want to talk
okay so i was doing research abrayu
showed me this and a few other people
did
basically our most watched recent video
is
something i you you've you've kicked ass
on instagram i think i've got the
youtube prize so far
um but because our most watched article
or most watched
video is on paid communities i think the
title is
how to make 20 million dollars a year
doing a paid community something like
that
um because we talked about a company
that does that and
now we'll make this title like how to
make like a million dollars or how to
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
doing a paid event and a bray you asked
me to talk about it so i came with a few
bullet points so
uh you want to talk about paid events i
want to because this is how the hustle
started so this is like your roots
and also we're starting to plan hustle
con again
and i have a feeling now more than ever
is the time to plan a paid event
a in-person paid event because i think
you can you can do really well because
there's going to be very little
competition and people are really eager
to go
we talked about it in the past uh about
events but
so sean if you go to the my the
million-dollar brainstorm document
uh you'll see i'm highlighting my name i
actually listed all of oh you're on your
phone so it might be a little
challenging
but i've actually listed a whole bunch
of our old profit and loss statements
from our events
if you hit metrics all time you can
actually see
our all-time metrics although actually
this only goes to 2018 so it's not all
time it's missing three years
but um you can kind of see the data you
can see how much money we're making and
we are making
uh in the first cup in the first year of
business about
i think um i think about 500 000
with like 84 percent margin right in our
first year business and so
let's talk about events so i'll and this
won't this isn't going to this is going
to be
a a 10-minute segment here probably but
basically
uh when i i first hosted my uh i
hosted my first event in june and the
event happened
or i decided to do it around june 1st
and the event
went place seven weeks later in august
and when i started i had close to
nothing i had
um a 200 person email list so there
wasn't like this oh it's easy for you
you had the hustle no no it didn't exist
there was no website there was just a
domain name called hustle cut
and i hosted this event in the first six
weeks it made about 60
thousand dollars in revenue and
fifty ish thousand dollars in profit and
a lot of people were surprised by that
it was but it wasn't that hard the
second event
you can see here explained so how did
you sell the sixty thousand dollars of
tickets during that process
i'm going to explain and and so i just
want to give a little give one more bit
of context the second event i think it
made about 150 to 200
000 in revenue and something like 150
in profit and i did these events six
months
apart apart um i would basically host an
event
go travel when i needed money i would
host another one and so
i was starting each time with close to
zero dollars so
so let me explain to you guys a little
bit about how i
started my events and what i would what
i would do if i was starting again which
is basically if i was starting again i
would do mostly the same stuff
but i think everyone in the next if
you're listening if you're willing to
spend
eight weeks working 40 hours a week
dedicated to this i think you could make
at least a hundred thousand dollars
profit
starting probably in september because
that's when
uh i think events conferences are going
to be okay
so anyway um the the biggest thing that
you have to do here is your email list
is the most important
thing so the hustlecon.com i launched
that website
on june 6th okay and within just a few
weeks we were averaging around a
thousand or 2000 unique visitors a day
and the email list jumped from about 200
people to about 2 500 people in seven
weeks
keep in mind at the time i didn't even
have a twitter so there was no twitter i
mean there was but i didn't use it
and so what i would do is hustlecon.com
was basically a landing page where i
explained what the event is and then
you'd enter your email
and that was called the front door the
side doors were all these blog posts
so i would write two to three blog posts
a week on each speaker
i would post that on hacker news people
would come to the website via the side
door
only five percent of them would say this
is interesting what's this website and
they would click the home page and i
would collect their email there
and then once i collected their email i
would send them a variety of
other blog posts that i'd written and at
the end of each blog post that i sent
them it would say ps this person is
speaking at hustle account on uh
august 1st in september you can get a
ticket right now for 10
off if you buy in the next 12 hours
right by the way the next 12 hours
that code was working all the time
it was always the next 12 hours the
countdown clock there's a simple plug-in
that you could buy and it just
starts it shows up so sorry guys i'm
sure everyone knows this now but
i don't even shopify wasn't popular at
that point so
um not everyone had that technology but
that's what we did
pretty easy pretty basic and in doing
that i'll give you an example of the
blog post because i remember like i
remember vividly the one you did about i
cracked
um which you kind of did like as i'm in
infographic i remember the one of
pandora so i would do
but explain what yeah explain what you
did and like
also these were speakers so you got
speakers to agree legit speakers to
agree before you even had
audience or anything yes which is the
second thing i'm going to talk about is
how to land a speaker but
the the blog post i basically would just
use forbes business insider all these
places
and just write a biography on the person
but i would do it in an interesting way
and eventually what happened is we would
create infographics so
um i had john who worked there and i
would say
john um here's the here's the bulleted
points of their life
turn it into an infographic please and
that's what we did we had infographics
it could have been a blog post which is
what i used to do we this time we made
infographics and it worked quite well
and it was basically
um i read the book made to stick and i
just copied that so i took
information about their company and i
made it really easy to understand so for
example pandora streams
this amount of music per hour
which is the equivalent of x y and z uh
they the reason
why they are able to do that as they
were one of the first people to launch
on the iphone
um and then i like i just tell that
story pretty simple
i thought it was simple very effective
now that's how we got our initial sales
now the thing about sales for events
it's incredibly stressful
the reason it's stressful is typically
of your sales come in the first five to
seven days and then
20 sometimes more 30 of your sales comes
in the last
like four or five days which means that
dead time
so you you want you have to get you got
to kick ass right out of the
right out of the gate so your first
launch series you need to kick ass your
first email launch series you need to do
really well
then there's a fair bit of dead time and
it feels we're failing we're failing
we're failing
and then the last 10 days or so you get
a wave of sales
and it all comes down to the last minute
and it is incredibly nerve-wracking and
anything can ruin it for example
a pandemic or if there was like a
terrorist attack if there was um
um um bad weather as simple as bad
weather
you're [__] and so you've been working
for seven weeks now eventually in our
case a whole year on this event
and you're screwed so it's very
stressful but the way that you can
actually make more money
and this is a something that i didn't
learn until later on for the tickets
you actually want to charge higher than
you than you can so let's say you want
to make a hundred thousand dollars
and you want to get a thousand people to
pay you a hundred dollars you always
charge
250. and then you give more you give
discounts in order to get to 100 average
sale price
and so you want in my opinion you want
to be very generous with discounts
but you want to charge a lot of money so
it anchors it at a high
at a high value yeah correct
and one other thing that you want to do
is you want to run this like an ecom
site
so for an ecomp site you say well i want
to make 100 grand this month
therefore i need to get um um
you know a hundred thousand people to my
a hundred thousand high quality people
on my website of which
three percent are going to convert i
know three percent are going to convert
because i'm
constantly tinkering with my landing
page the average sale value is going to
be x dollars
therefore this is how you do it now i
just need to get people to my website
that's what a lot of conference people
don't do that's what you should do
um and it works quite well um and then
finally
time is one of the best ways to create
sales so
you have to give discounts early on uh
and at the end
and you in the goal is you want to have
five
three to five tiers of pricing so you
want to have
early early bird and then early bird and
then
middle bird and then you're late okay
seriously this is the last reminder
you're late
like you because if you actually look so
can you actually see
um if you log into that doc i actually
put a chart of my very first event
uh from july of 24. you're gonna see big
spikes
every single one of those big spikes was
a new ticket tier
ending and there's a direct correlation
between the amount of revenue that i
made that day
and the amount of like the tier ending
and
um me sending an email blast reminding
people and i would email some two or
three times a day
in order to remind them wow and so
so you were going to hack a news for
traffic were you going anywhere else and
is that where you would go
today if you were doing it again well if
i was doing a tech event
if i was doing a tech event yes okay i
would go to hacker news
and what's the secret because a lot of
people will say um like you know
you know when i post on hacker news you
know i get you know
i know traffic i get down voted i get
what you know i get removed
because it's like well i would say the
obvious or not the obvious but
maybe obvious is well your content might
suck um
but i would say you i would actually
write content or
invite speakers who's who i knew i could
write about
that would go viral on hacker news and
also if you post 10 times only three
times it will go viral but
those three times you'll get like on
hacker news like 100 000 views
and so that it's like a hits driven
business so you got to post a ton
actually for it to work
and so you i remember when you were
doing your events so okay go sixty
thousand hundred
thousand i remember you were basically
like yeah hustle con brings in five
hundred thousand dollars
of revenue and like three hundred
thousand of that is profit or even more
sometimes
you know if i recall correctly so is
that typical that it was so profitable
or were you doing something different
than the average event host
yeah so when we would uh towards the
third fourth event
we could easily make seven hundred
thousand dollars i think maybe
let's just say easily five hundred
thousand i forget the exact but we're
making seven figures a year from events
and yeah we could do 50 margins but the
margins
get smaller as we actually grew and so
it was actually more profitable to do
some of these smaller events but
we did a few things that made us
profitable the first
i paid i'm now i'll say it's against the
contract but i'm going to say it
i paid casey neistat money to speak at
hustle con which is no surprise
it's like you could just google speaking
views but besides that
i've had probably three four 500 people
speak not once did i
ever pay for another speaker not one
time now
what i think i did do a few times is i
would pay for their flight but i
would pay economy i had sam yeagen who's
the ceo of match.com or was
who's very wealthy i paid a 350
flight from chicago to san francisco and
then maybe i think we got him a hotel
but i think it was just a 350 flight and
he actually
we reimbursed him for that and he would
email me to remind him oh you guys still
owe me that 350. so we didn't pay for
any speakers
other than casey neistat the second i
use a [__] ton of volunteers
because there's these kids and not
necessarily kids but
uh people who will email you once you
have an event to volunteer there's a
whole crew of them
and they want to be around you and uh
they do the work they do the work and
it's fun for them it's a lot of fun to
be part of something
that we would schedule it so they could
go see some talks but they didn't really
even care about the talks they just
wanted to be in the mix it was exciting
for them
and so these k these people love doing
that i use volunteers for everything
now the third part is actually important
and this might get some flack
but i would never work with or i would
try my hardest to avoid
union venues you want to avoid union
venues and ticketmaster venues
because if you work at a a lot of venues
sign contracts with ticketmaster
or something like that and you have to
work with ticketmaster
f that sorry ticketmaster you guys i
don't want to work with you
um and so the goal is to work within
some place that isn't bogged down by
that
or bogged down by a union because there
were some places where i would say all
right i want my volunteers to be at the
door and they would say
nope you have to have our union guy do
it we charge fifty dollars an hour you
have to have tenants right yeah it's
awesome so yeah so i remember you had
the sickest venue in oakland
um so right outside of san francisco and
it's the oakland whatever the theater
what's the theater called
the parable theater this thing it looks
so grand
and i remember you were like dude guess
how much this cost us i don't know if
you could say but
it was amazingly affordable like to rent
like
10 or 15 grand 10 15 grand for the two
days including all the people
yeah yeah and um and so you know when
you're doing an event that's bringing
700 grand like
and you you needed a kind of like a
notable nice big venue
i thought that was i i thought that
thing would be a hundred thousand
dollars right like my wedding venue
cost that much you know and it was like
right just for me to get married it
wasn't even like a business you know it
wasn't like you couldn't host
things and there's a few things which is
we i preferred hosting
conferences in places that typically
aren't used to hosting conferences so i
would do it there i did at the brava
theater in san francisco which i think i
don't remember exactly i'm pretty sure
that was three thousand dollars to host
an event there and i made a hundred
grand there right
so i would do it in venues that
typically weren't meant for conferences
and the reason why is if you go to a
hotel
or if you go to a conference center
they're gonna charge you for the union
stuff which is gonna add up really fast
which is actually going to be probably
2x the price of the hard cost of the
venue
and they're going to charge you
something like 50 ahead
for meals because you have to use their
caterer and that's something i would
avoid like crazy
instead i would find local mom-and-pop
places and i would call them and i would
say
uh eight dollars a meal i need them
prepped and ready to roll in in a box
can you do that right
um and i would get loads of cool people
to do that now the thing is is that in
my opinion the food
not really that important when it comes
to a conference some people will debate
me and say oh it's actually really
important
i got the cheapest [__] i possibly could
and i thought it was fun enough
and then that morning or that night or
the night before we would go to costco
and we would buy
every single danish that they had and we
would rent a truck and bring it there
and that's how we did stuff i did it on
uh really cheaply you don't always have
to do that but if you want to make a lot
of profit early on in your career it's a
great way to do it you also had
vendors that were like uh like i make a
keto breakfast bar you're like great
you're providing breakfast for
everybody you know that's your you're
paying me for marketing and
you're giving away free goods to my you
know oh you make vitamin water or
whatever like some
you're the you're the startup that wants
to be the next vitamin water well you
need to be here
and now that's the third that's the
fourth point which is
the way to make money is you get stuff
for free so
usually when i or when i first started i
only
typically had revenue from ticket sales
that's actually foolish
as you grow usually 50 50 ticket and
sponsors is your revenue
early on i didn't charge people that
much in sponsor money
instead anyone that emailed me that had
free stuff uh they would say hey we want
to sponsor you or
i would email people and say hey instead
of sponsoring us just bring your stuff
i've got 300 great people who are going
to be there will you come and bring 600
bottles of
vitamin water or whatever it is and they
would say absolutely i'm there and i
would say awesome i'm not charging you
any money i just want you to provide
free stuff right
and people did that we got someone to
pay 17 000 for the lunches because all
they did was hand out free stuff
and they would just get a little bit of
business from it and it would be worth
it so we got
tons and tons and tons of free stuff
right so the point of i actually didn't
provide anything
um and that is actually quite effective
and then a few more points
um a lot of times your sponsorship money
is going to come in the second year
because the first year you want to just
invite the sponsors there
and they're going to see that it
provides value and that you're the real
deal and you'll follow through and
they'll sponsor you the second year you
have to sell the second year
sponsorships and sometimes the second
your tickets
immediately like the day of or or 24
hours
after when you're in the heat of the
moment and they're seeing everything wow
this is great oh people are loving us
next year are you in title sponsorship
exactly and you want to do that right
away and the big guys like the intuits
and the microsoft's of the world
everyone's coming out they'll plan that
cycle two years out right so you can
actually book your two three four
sometimes it's it's that crazy and you
could get hundreds of thousands or even
millions of dollars from them right
um and so if you're gonna just so don't
worry about getting not getting sponsors
the first time
you'll get them uh the second time if
you do well and finally a few points on
speakers
so for content i didn't pay anyone but
what i would do is i would try to land
the i would put all my work in early on
to get the biggest speaker i possibly
could
right away right for example i convinced
the founder of pandora tim westergen
to speak and he was one of the first
people i had the truth is i kind of lied
about who else was coming i said all
these people were
all these other people were coming to
speak none of them had
had actually committed but once tim said
yes then i went to all those other
people and i told him tim was coming
and they again said yes and it was way
easier to land bigger name speakers
because i got the whale
anchor yeah so so and you've actually
published your cold emails that you sent
to speakers i think
on either your blog or neville's blog so
if people search what do they search for
to go find those i've
i've copy pasted those many times
already uh
because i'm like this is great how sam
did this yeah just um
sam parr neville cold emailing yeah uh
the the
and you'll see it and that stuff worked
well and i don't want to hear this
nonsense if you're starting this if
you're gonna start an event well you
already knew everyone
uh no i know everyone because i hosted
the of these events that's why i have a
huge network not because uh i had them
before i started this event yeah
um and so i think so uh i think what you
just said
is like a mountain of gold i think
people would pay you thousands of
dollars to hear that
how do you do this uh you know as a
consultant or a course or something
like that i think you you you gave them
the goods for free on this pod which i
think is amazing and that's what we're
all about
the other thing i would say is
i think there's it's not just about
making money doing this the way i look
at this if i'm
if i'm 22 years old and i don't want to
have like the traditional career
this is how you bring luck to yourself
you go host the party you go
host to host the event that's how sam
built his world-class network that's how
sam made a bunch of friends that's how
we met
you know like that's that's how these
things happen you bring luck to you
by going and taking a bunch of action
and all you have to do is be the hustler
who connects a bunch of dots
and do it in a topic area that you're
interested in so if you're super
interested in like
biohacking then you create the biohacker
cons conference you don't need to know
anyone you just go figure out who are
all the biohackers that i need to speak
here
how do i get in front of biohackers
while i need to create content about
you know biohacking and i need to get
that in front of people using reddit or
hacker news or some other
source i need to collect emails then i
need to keep telling great stories and
at the end of each of those stories i
need to say hey
if you like this kind of stuff there's a
thousand people like you including these
big names
at this event come you know like buy
your ticket now to join
i think you 100 should do that and i
think if you're going to do it
start planning now and it will change
your life um and it's actually not that
hard yeah
now last thing i'll wrap up with this
we've had ryan beagleman on the podcast
i actually did you see that email i said
that one so in 2017 i called people who
worked at ryan's company ryan's company
was
i mean i guess it was the other way
around my company was basically
ryan beagleman's company for tech and
business and entrepreneurship new
news uh ryan beagleman ran this thing
and started this thing called biz now
media which was basically
what my company is for real estate
hustle but for real estate
and so they did about 18 million dollars
in revenue the year they sold
which they sold for about 50 60 million
dollars 75 employees
their revenue was made up a third from
media so a third from advertising a
third from an event ticket sales a third
from sponsorships
the average revenue per event
uh team member was around three hundred
thousand dollars they did 250 events
around the year before they sold with
the average ticket price being eighty
thousand uh eighty dollars
and they wouldn't do an event unless
they could make eight uh ten thousand
dollars in revenue
most of the venues that they got were
free and
a lot of times programming was very
short so an event would start at 7am
it would kick off for an hour of
breakfast schmoozing followed by a
90-minute session for
panels and discussion and then hanging
out and talking and then you'd be back
in your office by 10 30.
and it was very effective and that's my
final point about events which is uh
the content actually not that important
all the speakers do and all the content
that you're
you're going to have all it does is it
brings the
a particular like-minded person and the
value is from
that people or those people being there
and the content is basically just a way
to as marketing to get the right people
and the way you know that that's true if
you go on youtube you can go watch all
this
talks from hustlecon like all the years
they're all on youtube
and they'll have like 2 000 views 3 000
views
you would think oh if people are coming
to hear these great speakers
they're willing to fly and pay you know
basically it's a thousand dollars all
in to go have this experience if you're
up from out of out of town
um which i think a lot of people are
then wow you know 10 times more people
should be just
consuming the content for free from the
comfort of their own home no it's not
what happens
people don't actually take the like it's
just like same thing with coursera
they have harvard's all of harvard's
courses online if you want the harvard
education you can go get it for free
right now online
turns out people don't want the harvard
education they want the harvard label
in the same way people don't want the
content from hustlecon
they want the experience and the network
and the kind of serendipity that can
happen by
going out there and getting amongst it
with a bunch of other people and like
putting yourself in that position people
that's really
the value that you get uh oh sorry
that's what i should say that's the
value you're providing
to the person who's deciding to come
don't fool yourself into thinking
they're coming to hear
this mind-blowing content although there
is this like sharad you put up where
you say that's why you're coming and
they say that's why they're going but
that's not really what you get out of it
that is that is absolutely correct and
uh i'm showing i
i actually if you put this thing or you
pull this thing up sean called
i don't really want to share this
publicly but you can look at it it's
called event metrics all time
i've listed 46 events that we've done
uh and i list out how many people showed
up how much revenue came from tickets
and how much revenue came from
sponsorships
there's this one event series that we
came up with called 2x
it stands for like two x chromosomes
meaning women have two x chromosomes
and it was a evening event that we would
host from nine pm
until uh i don't know uh whenever it
ended or sorry seven pm to nine p.m
and we would get a sponsor to pay for it
and we would invite these people to come
the first one had 400 people i'm pretty
sure towards the end
um we would get a thousand people so
here's one this one had 982 people
coming
we did 24 000 in revenue seven thousand
dollars in sponsors
thirty one thousand dollars in uh total
revenue
and then it looks like sixteen thousand
dollars in cost frankly we probably
didn't even need to spend that much
uh and we made fifteen grand in profit
and then we would host that
almost monthly in a variety of cities we
would do la chicago yada yada yada
one night it could make you 15 grand do
that 12 times a year
then you launch a paid community on top
of that you got yourself a multi-million
dollar business
inside 18 months if you just rinse and
repeat this it works
very well while building a great network
um and being
kind of the hub in between all these
different people the downside of course
is that
event planning [__] sucks events are
stressful and um
like you know it takes years off my life
every time i have to do an event so i
hate events but i
love this business model i love that you
laid it out for the person who
gets energy and like wants to do this
right like for me the nightmare job
would be wedding planner
um but for some people they dream of
being a wedding planner and so
for people who find that fun they like
that version of stress that flavor of
stress
i think you just laid out a pretty
amazing playbook uh okay yes
uh hopefully it's a good plan uh someone
can go do it and by the way if you just
google the hustle
2x literally like the number two and
then the word and then the letter x
i think what's it say we did we did
uh in 2018 from that event series
which is just i think we only want we
did about 200 000 in revenue and 110 000
in profit in 12 months from launch to
the first year it's pretty good anyway
that's that that's that's information on
paid events do you want to do one idea
before we go uh i'm kind of excited
about this yeah
so yeah okay have you heard of this
company future fitness
future fit yes i have tried it i was
i i tried it i was one of the i think i
was one of their early users
and they did a good job of onboarding me
hand
on boarding me you know nicely but the
product didn't stick with me
well so i don't know exactly how it
ended up being but when i first signed
up
it wasn't that unique but it was slick
it was just you have a personal trainer
so i pay them 100
a month a personal trainer made a plan
for me and i would tell them what sports
i cared about what i want to be good at
and i would talk to them i think
weekly about my athletic or about my
progress
that's what it was when i first signed
up but it was all tracked via
a watch and they would send you an apple
watch
yeah so okay so i think i think it's
evolved a little bit so basically what
future fit
is is it's your it's a personal trainer
it's really like an accountability coach
and that's what i'll call this bucket of
ideas i want to brainstorm within
uh of accountability coaching so
futurefit basically says hey
okay a personal trainer is like 100 per
session
you know so so let's say it's 150 per
session in in big cities like new york
or
sf and then you know a gym membership is
like 15 a month
right so you have this like big
discrepancy there where one is like
one session is over a hundred dollars
the other one a whole month is fifteen
but then there's something in between
what these guys did was they said well
look
for 150 a month you're going to get a
fitness coach
and they're not going to come you know
they're not going to be with you you
know like sort of spotting you while you
do your bench press
they're going to be spotting the
accountability of you actually working
out
so what they would do they would ask you
about your goals then they would send
you a customized workout plan based on
your goals and
in reality they just have a huge library
of workouts it's like oh
guys you want to build muscle here's a
bunch of workouts to choose from
you know a woman who wants to have tone
but
okay you know here's a bunch of workouts
to to use so the trainer sends you a
workout that's you know for you
based on your goals and then they'll
kind of text you and be like hey did you
get that workout in
and they also connect to apple watch so
they can kind of see if you did it and
they can say hey great job or they can
be like hey what's up man
like don't don't let go of the rope like
keep keep going like we said we wanted
to do this
keep keep doing this and so i think this
is
a very smart idea and a very smart
business
model which is basically the core thing
that stops most people from being fit is
the habit
of fitness the habit of exercise yes if
you work out with a trainer you can get
more out of every workout
but for most people the bigger problem
is just sticking to the workout
like schedule and routine and actually
like not
just feeling lazy and not going to the
gym you know and so i like that they
have basically accountability
is the primary feature of this app and
so i like that
there is knowledge there is tech
technique but it's packaged around
accountability so i was talking to
ben and my right-hand man ben and he was
like you just had a kid
i'll say how's it going how's baby life
you know you getting any sleep
he's like actually we hired a sleep
coach
same model woman woman in texas and she
basically
what's it called so she's just like an
independent person there's not even like
a service so
we talked before about patel which is
like my friend damian who's starting
this company to do this
so he just used you know somebody he
found that's like known to do this in
texas
and so he just said uh great like you
know here's kind of what we're doing
today like here's my
here's my current like routine you know
we'd like to be getting some sleep and
here's my
rough schedule here's my wife's you know
rough schedule so we'd like to make it
work
we don't want to have the baby cry it
out so that's like our constraints so
they
you know your coach basically downloads
your goals and your kind of like your
limitations
your constraints i said great i got a
program for you and
i was like oh wow what's her technique
he's like honestly it's like not that
much he's like you know just he needs
snap at this time specifically and like
during these times he needs to stay
awake so make sure you're playing with
him or you're feeding him you're doing
something then don't let him fall asleep
and then like at this time you're gonna
put him to bed every single night and
like
you know when he cries you're gonna go
in for this many minutes and whatever
it's like a little bit of a coaching on
the technique
but he's like honestly it's not the
technique he's like it's just the
accountability of like
she asks us okay what time did he nap
what time did he wake up today what time
how did he sleep last night
and because we keep having to report to
this lady it forces us to not like
throw in the towel and just be like oh
man like i don't know i give up just let
him sleep if you want to sleep right now
it's like no
our coach told us he needs to stay awake
during these daytime hours so that he's
going to sleep well at night
he's like dude it's amazing he's now
sleeping eight hours a night he's two
months old like life
like the first month was so rough and
the second month is so much better
just with this coach he's like and it's
not even like anything that we couldn't
have just googled a schedule
he's like it's how having this woman who
we're accountable to to maintain the
schedule
is much more important than like just
taking a schedule off the internet of a
in the same way like you can go download
a workout off the internet but this
coach helps you stay accountable to
actually doing those workouts
so i thought so okay yeah let's break
this down a little bit let's talk about
what
this could work so i actually use a
service called uh do you have your phone
on you yeah
okay go to my mybodytutor.com
my body tutor like a tutor like a like a
you know like a
coach tutor right look at that website
how ugly is that oh my gosh so i'm on a
1990 i'll just describe this i'm on
what looks like a 1990s website it says
at the very top
it's like this awful logo and then it
says celebrating 2007 to 2021 14 years
so that you know this has been around
for a while it looks like it's 2007.
yeah
and so what it is it's a guy named adam
gilbert and he's got a variety
of people who are on the um on the
payroll
and you pay i was paying 500 a month
and all i would do it was very simple i
would every time i ate a meal
i would take a picture and he would
comment on it once a week
i would do a 20 or 10 minute phone call
and they would say how's it going
and the stress that knowing i was being
watched
right made me change my habits and i got
and i
lost weight it's almost like when you're
writing in a google doc
that stress makes you do it that's what
this is right when you see somebody
else's cursor there okay so
so i just started using one because i
was like oh when when you told me about
this i started looking into like okay
where else could you do this and i
thought well it's anywhere you have a
goal
and that the goal like it's not that you
need like some specific strategy that no
one's ever heard of
it's like no you kind of even know what
to do it's just helpful to have somebody
who's on your side in your corner
supporting you and keeping you focused
keeping you on track and so
productivity i think is a big one so uh
you're probably like me you know you
have like goals for what you want to do
and
probably everybody listening to this is
like you know i want to
make five more sales this month i want
to get five new clients or i want to
grow 20
this month or i want to like grow my
email list to 5 000 people or whatever
it doesn't matter what your goal is you
have a goal i want to get promoted um
so you have a goal and then like your
progress
is basically like sometimes you need
tactical help like strategic advice
but really what i what i've found for
myself is that
you just need pressure i need
accountability i need to make each day
count and if i just get like you know
like 25 out of the 30 days a month to
count
i'm gonna actually hit my goals but if
i'm like uh i kind of had an
off day there i was distracted i went
down this rabbit hole of doing this
other thing
oh i got stressed out or you know like
whatever if i lose four of those
days of like i didn't actually like make
the most of that day
now i'm down to like 20 days out of the
30 and i'm like
i'm off track i didn't get my goal and
like what's that difference of like
staying on track towards your thing and
and off is like for me it's
accountability it's why i work well with
a co-founder
because a co-founder helps you like
every day you're kind of focused on all
right what do i need to do today
do i get it done at the end of the day
did i like make enough progress or not
like that sort of thing and so
i found this service so you can do this
actually if you want
uh anybody who's listening to this so
you can basically go and um
it's called what's called we focus and
it's basically you and your coach
and it helps you focus on getting to
your goals uh for your professional
goals so anything you want to do with
your work or your projects
and so you just text this number right
it's like i'll put in the description
it's four three four four three four
five oh five
four seven six nine i'll put it in the
comments but basically it's
uh four three four five oh five grow is
the kind of like the handle of it
and you pay 150 bucks a month and you
basically get a coach and the coach
basically just texts you like at first
it's like all right what's your goals
for the month all right
it's uh it's april what would make for a
great april
and honestly just that question is
actually pretty powerful because you got
to like articulate it you say something
but then you realize like
oh i want to really make progress on my
book
well what does make progress mean like
you want to have a draft
that's like 100 pages would that be the
goal and so they help you like actually
set a good goal
and then on a day-to-day basis they sort
of like it's kind of like
the manager you need it's like they kind
of nag you enough to make you get it
done
but they're not annoying this is and and
this is wefocus.com there's no app
there's no there's no website there's no
app no
it's just a phone number it's literally
just a phone number
and so they they have these like coaches
wow okay so i can't do it
my friend was using it and so so i was
like okay what's the number so you just
gave me four three four five oh five
four seven six nine and so anyways uh
they have like a wait list i think but
you
i got let in recently so so basically
you pay 150 bucks and then what happens
is the coach will basically say in the
morning they'll be like all right great
like we said your goal was
let's say to you know grow revenue by 20
this month
and you said you're going to do that by
like ramping up your sales efforts so
it's like all right cool
hey hey you know it'll be like hey sam
like um like let's get it today like
you know what what would make today a
great day like how what would be really
satisfying at the end of the day if
you've done what
and you're like i want to make like 10
10 sales calls like all right great
and then like in the evening or the
afternoon they'll check in they'll be
like you know like remember keep
you know keep the vision in mind we want
to get there like go for it make sure
you get those 10 in today
at the end of the day they'll still text
you something they'll be like you know
hey did you get the 10 calls in you know
if not you know what do you think held
you up today let's reflect on it
or if you got it it's like awesome like
you know high five
plus like think back to one of those
calls where you really kicked ass
like like what made it kick ass and so
it just helps you
and you can put in as much or as little
as you want so if you just want it to be
like
just check in with me once a day or once
a week it'll do that but if you want it
to be like more reflective like i like
it where it's like
all right let me let me think back on my
day like what's something i could have
done better today so i actually disagree
with you
strongly on this one this is far too
broad i would want to make it
incredibly narrow so for example
uh we guarantee you're going to be a
better writer or sorry
the service to make you write more right
and you have to log in
every day and if you don't get a
thousand words you get um
you get your coach yells at you like
dude what the [__] do you even want
do you really actually want to be a good
writer because you're not writing um
and so i actually would make it far more
vertical specific
for yes so relationship i think could
really actually work
you know what i would do another one i
would just call it gratitude right i'm
going to make you happier by
so hey you're going to probably yeah why
didn't you write here what you were
thankful for this morning
what the hell um you could show
gratitude um what else we said
you said relationships i actually don't
know how you would do a relationship one
well i think i think
i think for relationships it's like you
know people think relationship is
when people say they need they want a
better relationship what they're really
saying is
uh [__] my partner does these things and
it annoys me why don't they just not do
those things and not annoy me
and in reality to make a better
relationships like you need to be the
best version of yourself in the
relationship and if your partner agrees
to do the same
for themselves like you'll have an
amazing relationship over time
and so so what you would do for
relationships is you would basically say
awesome what is the best version of you
you're going to bring to your
relationship and it would just coach you
on you doing your part
and not doing tit-for-tat measuring oh
i'll behave if my
i'll be great if they are great it's
like well that's a recipe for failure
uh it's i'll be great because that's who
i am that's what works and in the
context of being a great boyfriend great
girlfriend great husband whatever
okay so that could work for
relationships so we've
uh diet and fitness is easy i think
that's easy yeah you know you have to
run you have to hit this mileage
anywhere you have a goal so it could be
like as narrow as people who are
training for a triathlon that i know a
lot of people hire like a marathon
our marathon coach who helps them like
structure their ramp up running and all
that stuff so it could be as
narrow as any it's anything you have a
goal on so the reason i like this one is
because
my i have like goals when it comes to
work right and
i know that if i can just if i can be a
little bit more productive every single
day if i can be a little bit better at
my projects make a little more progress
every day
150 in a month is like nothing compared
to the value i create
by actually doing better in my project
so it's anywhere you have a goal
fitness diet relationships um and so you
know whatever those goals are for people
i think that accountability coaching is
going to be a bigger thing because
it's like anywhere that there's a like
so for example relationships you have a
relationship therapist or a couple's
therapy right so you have this thing you
could go pay
150 an hour or you could read a 10
book well now there's something in the
middle it's like a human on the other
side
but you don't have to pay 150 an hour
you pay 100 a month because they're
digital and they're managing
multiple clients this way in a light
touch model same thing with fitness you
could have a personal trainer
or you could have a gym membership or
this is the thing in the middle of your
accountability coach
so same thing with you know work you
could have an executive coach
who's like you know thousands of dollars
as you're as your ceo coach
uh or whatever your job is if you're not
a ceo but you have an executive coach
or you could really read a management
book well this is something in the
middle
it's a way for you to be better at work
with accountability coach so that's the
model i see here and i bet there's a
bunch of areas where this could apply
um how big do you think future fit is so
future fit says that they're
they're trying to get to a thousand
coaches this year they've raised 35
million dollars
uh um series b so i think they're you
know they're probably doing fairly well
and they're kind of in that peloton
model right they just need like you know
if you're making 150
subscription per month it doesn't take
that much to be at 15 million dollars
you know a year of of revenue doesn't
take that much to be a 150 million
dollars a year
like it is an achieve these are
achievable numbers as you get to like 10
000 subscribers
a hundred thousand subscribers type of
thing i don't know what they're supposed
to so the issue is churn though
the issue is of course churn yeah
because and i think that's why
the harder the goal um the more the
churn this is the unfortunate part of
this business is like fitness
people fall off that horse and even if
your product is great
sometimes they just stop wanting to work
out eat right you know so i think diet
is going to have a lot of turn i think
fitness can have a lot of churn
um work i think we'll have a little bit
less turn but maybe
you know still will have churn uh
relationships i don't know where that
would fall
but i don't know i find this pretty
fascinating so and i i i i i'm trying it
for a few days i like it
have you invested in future fit no i
invested in fitness ai which is an ai
version of it
i wouldn't invest in future fit because
of the churn that was that would be
something i would be concerned about
um but i would love to own one of these
companies
yeah totally i for sure would like to
own it um
do we want to do one more no i gotta run
um all right well dude by the way do you
know that
we get criticized for irish goodbyes we
just end the podcast
it's our thing i actually do the same
thing with my family too like if i'm
talking to my mom or my sister
like there's no like okay well you know
i'm gonna go run to the store now so
it's been great chatting no it's like
gotta go bike or i'll just be like bye
and i'll just hang up the phone yeah i
do the exact same thing whatever
they know the deal and they can do the
same right back to me you don't even
need to tell me why you need to leave
if you need to leave you just yell by
and you hang up before i reply
i do this at gatherings too i don't i
actually don't say goodbye i just walk
out
um yeah i do that too because i think
it's i think goodbyes are pointless
like what's the point it's just like i
don't know it's just a lot of effort for
something that's uncomfortable for me to
do and like
uh yeah once i've decided i'm moving on
to my next activity like i've moved on
already it's too late
i'm here i'm there i'm not here anymore
i'm gone right
like i gave you the beginning in the
middle i don't need an n the ending's
stupid
you just need the it's it's pointless um
all right so that's the end of the
podcast
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back